Die NASA selbst spricht davon, dass dieser
Plan die gesamte Raumfahrt revolutionieren
könnte: Denn durch einen nuklearen Antrieb
würde sich die Reisezeit von Langzeitmissionen
wie etwa zum Mars enorm reduzieren.
Und das widerum würde das gesundheitliche
Risiko für Astronautinnen und Astronauten
drastisch senken!
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal
und aktiviert die Glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen!
Eine Reise zum Mars würde nach Schätzungen
von Fachleuten nur noch drei bis vier Monate
dauern, wenn Raumschiffe sich durch nuklearen
Antrieb fortbewegen.
Auf dem Treffen des National Space Council
(NSC) sprach der NASA-Chef Jim Bridenstine
von dem nächsten Riesenschritt der Menschheit
durch Nukleartechnologie der nächsten Generation.
Der Rat NSC wurde 2017 von US-Präsident Donald
Trump wieder eingesetzt, um die Weltraumpolitik
der USA zu steuern.
Wichtig bei all dem: Der nukleare Wärme-Antrieb,
der derzeit im Gespräch ist, ist nicht zu
verwechseln mit den bereits bestehenden Radioisotopengeneratoren
(RTG), die die NASA seit Jahrzehnten einsetzt.
Hier wird Wärme durch den radioaktiven Zerfall
von Plutonium erzeugt, die dann in Elektrizität
umgewandelt wird.
Dadurch können dann Geräte und Raumfahrzeuginstrumente
angetrieben werden.
Beim nuklearen Wärme-Antrieb wird durch die
Kernspaltung Wärme erzeugt, die dann wiederum
Treibstoff wie Wasserstoff mit krasser Geschwindigkeit
verbrennt.
Das würde die Reisezeit von Langzeitmissionen
sogar halbieren.
Dadurch würde eine Reise zum Mars nur noch
halb so lange dauern - und das hätte enorme
Vorteile für die Besatzung.
Denn vor allem die schädliche Strahlung im
All stellt ein hohes Risiko für Astronautinnen
und Astronauten dar.
Und kein Raumschiff dieser Welt kann diese
gefährliche Strahlung so gut abhalten, wie
es die Atmosphäre, die Ozonschicht und das
Magnetfeld der Erde tun.
Auf der ISS, der Internationalen Raumstation
ist das weniger ein Problem, weil das Erdmagnetfeld
einiges davon bereits weiter Außen abhält.
Die ISS kreist nur in einer Höhe von 400
Kilometern um die ERrde.
Mars-Missionen, die demnächst angepeilt werden,
bedeuten aber auch, dass die Besatzung eine
große Strahlendosis abbekommt.
Und fest steht: Sie kann das menschliches
Gewebe und Nervenzellen tatsächlich schädigen,
da sie die Aluminiumhülle des Raumschiffes
durchdringen.
Medizin Teams befürchten, dass die Strahlung
deutliche Auswirkungen auf die Astronauten
haben könnte: Beispielsweise könnten die
emotionale Stabilität und die Reaktionsfähigkeit
nachlassen.
Aber auch das Krebsrisiko steigt durch die
Strahlung.
Forschungsteams weltweit sind dabei, Medikamente
zu entwickeln, die die Wirkung der kosmischen
Strahlung abfedern könnten.
Beispielsweise, indem die menschlichen Zellen
strahlenresistenter gemacht werden.
Nach der Einschätzung von Experten und Expertinnen
ist jedenfalls klar: Diese Strahlung stellt
eine der größten Gefahren bei einer Mars-Mission
dar.
Durch eine Verringerung der Reisezeit würde
ja aber auch die Strahlendosis verringert
werden.
Dazu Jim Bridenstine: “Das ist absolut wegweisend
für das, was die NASA erreichen will.
Dieser Plan ermöglicht es uns, das Leben
bei der Reise zwischen Erde und Mars wirklich
vor der Strahlung zu schützen”.
Doch auch für Waffensysteme wurde der Einsatz
von nuklearem Antrieb von Raumschiffen diskutiert.
Raumschiffe, die in der Nähe der Erde kreisen,
könnten somit schneller denjenigen Waffensystemen
ausweichen, die ins All abzielen.
Laut Joseph Maguire, ein hochrrangiger Regierungsbeamte
der Vereinigten Staaten, werden solche Waffen
von Russland und China entwickelt.
Demnach könnten diese im Kriegsfall einen
Angriff auf US-amerikanische und alliierte
Raumfahrtsysteme starten.
Diskutiert wurde solch ein nuklearer Antrieb
auch bezüglich Abwehr von Asteroiden.
Durch die Entwicklung eines Hochleistungslaser
könnte zudem auch die Zerstörung von Weltraumschrott
möglich werden.
Finanzielle Hilfen hat die NASA jedenfalls
schon für das Projekt bekommen: Allene 125
Millionen US-Dollar sollen laut einem aktuellen
Gesetzentwurf bereitgestellt gestellt werden,
um nukleare Antriebstechnologien zu erforschen..
Der US-Kongress stellte zudem weitere 100
Millionen US-Dollar in diesem Jahr bereit.
Und so wundert es nicht, dass kein einziges
Wort über die Gefahren eines nuklearen Antriebssystems
in der Raumfahrt verloren wurde!
Dabei ist das Risiko einer radioaktiven Kontaminierung
nicht von der Hand zu weisen, falls ein solches
Raumschiff mal abgeschossen würde oder aus
einem anderen Grund auseinanderbricht.
Wie funktioniert der Hyperantrieb?
Anklicken, Anschauen und Astro Comics TV-Abonnieren!
Bis Dann, Bleibt dran!